INTERVIEW WITH JEFF SESSIONS
LATER TONIGHT WITH
SHANNON BREAM.
THAT IS ""FOX NEWS @ NIGHT","
11:00 EASTERN TIME ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
THE SANCTUARY STATE CRACKED
OUTCOMES AS REPUBLICANS ARE
REACHING OUT TO LATINOS AND
OTHERS WHO COULD MAKE A MAJOR
DIFFERENCE IN NOVEMBER'S MIDTERM
ELECTION.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
THAT STORY TONIGHT FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
>> THE NEW REPUBLICAN PLAN TO
KEEP THE HOUSE, HOUSE PARTIES.
>> THERE ARE NO THEY ARE MONEY
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT SUPPORT
DEMOCRATS.
>> RNC CHAIR IS MEETING HISPANIC
ACTIVISTS AND VOTERS IN PLACES
LIKE FLORIDA, ARIZONA, NEVADA,
TRYING TO ENGAGE A CONSTITUENCY
THAT BROKE FOR CLINTON OVER
TRUMP BY NEARLY 40 POINTS.
BUT DOESN'T ALWAYS REPRESENT A
HUGE SLICE OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTRIC TO COME BY JUST 8% OF
TOTALS IN '06 COME '10, AN '14
ACCORDING TO EXIT POLLS.
THE G.O.P. PERSONAL TOUCH COMES
AS PRIMARY VOTERS SENT TWO
HISPANIC WOMEN TO CONGRESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TEXAS HISTORY.
>> SINCE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
WE WILL REACH OUT TO COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVEN'T TRADITIONALLY BEEN
REPUBLICAN, THAT I DON'T KNOW
OUR MESSAGE, AND TELL THEM ABOUT
THE GOOD THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN SHARE OUR
MESSAGE IS IF WE SHOW UP RATES
BECAUSE THE BIG CONCERNS ABOUT
REPUBLICANS AT A RECENT MEETING
IN CORAL GABLES, FLORIDA, WHERE
THE ECONOMY AND SOLUTIONS FOR
HURRICANE RAVAGED PUERTO RICO.
>> AND I AM VERY SURE THAT OUR
PRESIDENT DOES NOT KNOW A LOT OF
THE TRUTH OF WHAT IS REALLY
HAPPENING IN PUERTO RICO.
>> THOUSANDS OF PUERTO RICANS
ARE STILL DISPLACED AND LIVING
IN FLORIDA, WHICH ACTIVISTS
THINK REPRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE G.O.P.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT MANY, MANY
FAMILIES WILL STAY AND OUR JOB
IS TO TELL THEM THE MESSAGE OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
A SPEAKER DNC CHAIRMAN TOM PEREZ
TELLS FOX AS LONG AS REPUBLICANS
ARE THE PARTY OF TRUMP, HISPANIC
VOTERS WILL BE A TOUGH SELL.
>> LATINOS JUDGE PEOPLE BY THEIR
WORDS AND ACTIONS AND THIS
PRESIDENT HAS MADE ONE STATEMENT
AFTER ANOTHER AND TAKEN ONE
ACTION AFTER ANOTHER,
DISPARAGING AND DEMORALIZING,
AND DISENFRANCHISING LATINOS.
LOOK AT THE PUERTO RICAN
SITUATION.
PUERTO RICANS ARE SECOND-CLASS
CITIZENS IN DONALD TRUMP'S
OPINION.
>> REPUBLICANS THINK THEY HAVE
REASON TO BELIEVE HOT-BUTTON
ISSUE AFFECTING HISPANIC
FAMILIES WILL BE THE DECIDING
ISSUE IN THE MIDTERM SPRAYED
SPEAK OF A PARTY THAT WE HAD
TODAY, IMMIGRATION DID NOT
COME UP, NOT AN ISSUE THAT
ANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS TALKED
ABOUT.
>> SO BASED ON THAT, BETWEEN NOW
AND NOVEMBER, LOOK FOR
REPUBLICANS TO TRY TO HIGHLIGHT
THE ECONOMY AND LOOK FOR